let's go next to taffin
from california that is not a name i've
seen before taffin
oh no yeah my i don't know where my
parents got their name from
interesting you've never asked i mean i
mean actually i do know where it's from
but it's like such a silly story like
but um no but uh
my question is um this is something i'm
kind of noticing and it's kind of like a
question that's raised in my head that i
think
might actually have some implications
for the republican party
okay but um i recently saw this video of
like a bunch of um
like trump supporters in georgia and it
was some like rally or protest or
whatever
and one of the guys got up and started
shouting about how they were going to
destroy the republican party
for betraying them right and this is
something i'm starting to think
like see more and more and i think it's
more of a trend now
where i'm seeing more infighting in the
republican party rather than actually
like
expect going towards any like democrats
and stuff
and looking back i think one of the
things that made the republican party so
strong
was their like coalition building and
what i'm thinking
is that well do you think that there's a
possibility that like
how radicalized that the republicans and
trump have made the base
could actually start like making blow
back against the republicans
yes we're seeing more and more that a
bunch of like uh republicans
like obviously they've supported some of
this stuff but they can't support all of
it
and the moment you know that they go
against it like we saw with tucker
carlson the people started like um
slamming back against them and uh do you
think that could start making some like
blowback or repercussions to the
republican party i would love to think
that the
answer is yes but i think the most
likely scenario
is that once trump is gone and joe biden
is sworn in
there's this phrase return to the mean
and
i think that we are going to see
republicans basically go back
to where they were before trump which is
democrats really are the enemy you'll
still have these
fringes of the republican party that
will say the problem is the republican
party
isn't right enough or whatever the case
may be but i think for the most part
you'll see republicans going back to
exactly what they were where you see
the low tax pro business conservatives
uh
allied with the evangelicals allied with
the libertarians
all united that democrats are really bad
people really bad they're socialist
communists etc
and i don't think that the fracturing of
the republican party that you're seeing
right now is going to
persist now i could be wrong and if it
does persist it could be great for the
left but i'm not optimistic i think the
republican party will go right back to
what they were before donald trump
yeah you're probably right i just got
excited seeing that in georgia because
the runoff's coming out
yeah i think i i also saw people um some
some
republicans saying we we need to punish
the republican party by not voting at
all in georgia
in the georgia senate right now i
thought it was going to which sounds
great
i mean i know they're never going to
vote like democrat but i could see them
like just not voting
exactly exactly and i hope that happens
because it could actually i mean the
polls are really tight in both of those
races they're essentially statistical
ties
if if a million more democrats register
and a million republicans decide not to
vote or something you know
whatever numbers that alone could flip
the results and give democrats the
senate which would just be amazing
no yeah yeah so i guess at least in the
short term there's some benefit to be
made out of that
yeah there may i do think republicans
will go back to what they were
but in the next two and a half months
there may actually be an advantage to be
gained from uh
uh from from the chaos and and let's
hope that that's the case
okay yeah well thanks for taking my
question david all right my pleasure i
appreciate uh
very much appreciate the phone call uh
that is going to do it for calls
for today as always you know my deep
apologies to everybody i was not able to
get to but they're
it's a good problem to have that there
are more
callers than time for calls hope
everybody
in the u.s has a great thanksgiving i'll
take a few audience questions after the
break and then we'll be back at it very
strongly
at the start of next week privacy.com is
one of our sponsors and they're giving
you five dollars
just for using their free service at
privacy.com
pacman privacy is a service i've been
using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your
real card number stays completely
private
and you do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number
in your web browser on the phone you can
create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits
freeze them delete them whenever you
want i especially love it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future if you're ordering
food over the phone why do i need to
give a restaurant my real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman